[Music]
little nausea is expecting
well kind of the blessings are literally
knocking me out at this point the latest
blessing is the rapper's debut
full-length studio album montero
[Music]
announced this album will drop on
september 17th and the news came with
these
[Music]
yup the musician did a full-on maternity
shoot to celebrate his baby sporting a
prosthetic bump flower crown and even
sharing a sonogram he also posted this
reveal to tick tock
[Music]
explained the idea was born no pun
intended out of a conversation he had
with his stylist quote she was like wow
this all comes together your album your
baby
i was like yeah this is my baby huh as a
joke she was like yeah you should do a
pregnancy shoot and well now we have
these pics it's amazing lil nazax's
photo shoot comes just days after he
kinda trolled fellow rapper drake's
latest album launch after drake shared
the cover art for certified lover boy a
series of emojis depicting pregnant
women they'll call me by your name
singer posted this mummified version
featuring pregnant men i mean i'm just
like extremely thankful and happy now
this whole pregnancy thing doesn't stop
there because on thursday little nausea
tweeted to his followers let me get
offline all of this negative energy is
not good for the baby
and there's more lil nas x news where
that comes from not only is he releasing
his own record but he's also featured on
ellen john's new album i mean these kids
are rocking it on wednesday elton
revealed details about the lockdown
sessions the track list featuring a
series of collaborations with a-list
talent again including low nas x which
doesn't come as a huge surprise because
back in may the rocket man singer told
e.t this
and of course uh little nice x who is a
hero of mine
[Music]